what no give me kisses
hey
give me kisses
some west isn't here for his famous mom
interrupting his tv time having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot on monday kim kardashian
posted a few clips to her instagram
story trying to snuggle up to her
two-year-old son while he's watching tv
along with the caption quote all i want
is a little attention but he doesn't
care
what no give me kisses
hey
give me kisses
give me hey hey
you're paying me no attention give me
kisses som was having none of it give me
kisses yeah the tiny tot is already too
cool for school something the kkw beauty
founder revealed during a recent stop at
the ellen degeneres show and psalm is
the one that was wearing the giant chain
around his neck is that song yes oh my
god he wears this big giant chain wait
did you say fake
[Applause]
it's fake it's not it's not it's not
yeah so that gold chain kim says it's
real it's not it's not oh my god it's
huge i know but it's not how can he keep
his head up it's like it's it looks like
a wrestler's belt or something it's not
fake fun no it's not oh my god
i just assumed because it was so huge
it's hilarious
yeah no and when it comes to his reality
star mama salm isn't the only one giving
her sass you just gotta roll with it
earlier this month kim's eight-year-old
daughter north totally called her out
for seemingly using a different voice on
social media okay i'm gonna open it and
show you guys
why do you talk different why do i talk
different for what when your videos for
my videos i'm the same human being i
don't talk different
how do i talk different
guys do you think i talk different when
i'm talking about contour yeah
yeah so even kim's sister kourtney
kardashian's nine-year-old daughter
penelope agreed
you do too penelope how do i talk
small
guys
i got this
is that we is that what i say is that
what i sound like
of course kim shares north and her
siblings saint chicago and psalm with
her ex kanye west and while kim may have
filed for divorce from the grammy winner
back in february a source tells e.t he's
still trying to win her back
kim and kanye's relationship is in a
much healthier space they have been
speaking a lot more frequently and have
been spending more time together on
their own and as a family kanye is
totally trying to win kim back and she
is considering it but he still has a lot
to prove to her him and i have been best
friends for a really long time and just
been in each other's lives the source
adds that kim is quote hopeful and knows
kanye is on the right track quote a part
of them both want to have a happy
healthy and faithful partnership like
they once had